قال رئيس الهيئه العليا المستقله
للانتخابات في تونس فاروق بوعسكر ان نسبه
الاقتراع العامه في الجوله الثانيه من
الانتخابات التشريعيه بلغت 11 وثلاثه
اجزاء من 100% حسب النتائج الاوليه واقرب
عسكر بتدني نسبه المشاركه داعيا لنقاش
موضوعيا بشان ذلك وقد جرت الانتخابات في
ظل انقسام سياسيا وازمه الاقتصاديه
ومعايشيه ودعاء رئيس جبهه الخلاص الوطنيه
احمد نجيب الشابي الى
رحيل الرئيس السعيد وتنظيم انتخابات
الرئاسيه المبكره تكون خطوه الاولى لمسار
الاصلاحيه كامل واشار الشابي الى ان 90%
من التونسيين اداروا ظهورهم للعمليات
الانتخابيه
من جانب الاخر اعتبرت شبكه مراقبون في
تونس ان المسار الانتخابيه خلق منذ
انطلاقه
المبادئ الاساسيه التي تقوم عليها كل
عمليه انتخابيه من مساواه وشفافيه
واستقلاليه ووصفت الشبكه في تقريرها عن
سير المرحله الثانيه من الانتخابات
التشريعيه التي جرت امس حجب عدد من رؤساء
مكاتب الاقتراع للمعطيات والارقام لانه
سابقه خطيره من قبل هيئه الانتخابات ويمثل
خلق صارخا لمبدا الشفافيه مما يسهم في
اهتزازه الثقه في العمليه الانتخابيه حسب
ما جاء في هذا التقرير
حاجه جديده بلغيه بشفافيه وايه تحت معلومه
يوم الاقتراع
يعني حاجه حجب عدد من رؤساء الملكات
والاختيار المعطيات المتعلقه بعد
المخترعين عن منظمه المجتمع المدني
والصحافيين في اغلب الدول الانتخابات هذه
الحجم متعمد ولا ما نعرفوش مانيتا
مع العلم هذا التعامل سابقا خطيره في رصيد
هيئه الانتخابات
الثقه في العمليه الانتخابيه كما اثر هذا
التضييق بشكل مباشر على عمل مكملات
المجتمع المدني
بدورها طلبت حركه النهضه في تونس باستقاله
رئيس الجمهوريه قيس سعيد وفتح المجال
لاجراء انتخابات الرئاسيه مبكرا وذرت
مرافق العمليه الانتخابيه من خلالات جسيمه
حسب تعبيرها